Here is a summary of the kind of Heuristics that an AI agent might use in
criminal concept learning. You only come across five of them,
require-link, forbid-link, drop-link, enlarge-set and
climb-tree. Here is another one called close-interval, let's look at it briefly.
Let's go to David's example of a child having a dog and
suppose that child has only come across dogs that were very small in size.
Now the child comes across a large dog. In that case the child might change
the concept definition, expand the range of values that the dog can take,
that dog size can take so that the larger dog can be included. So the difference
here being that it's values can be continuous like size of a dog and
sort of indiscreet as in the other hero sticks